[Music]
here today to talk about the type of
dangers that occur in in data science
work in terms of the impact it has
externally not kind of like construction
operation danger not danger to data
scientists but the type of danger that
can be can impact people when our models
are deployed and by deployed I don't
only mean in you know in in production
in a tech cycle production but deployed
in in society at large and what I use
the term data scientists I mean we've
all got a thousand different definitions
of over data scientists I'm really
interested in talking about people such
as many of us who are involved in the
production of models that are deployed
at scale essentially so you could also
call this talk product manager or the
most that may even be more apt
essentially I'm just I'm just having a
dig at product managers there so what
what what we need to talk about today
essentially is where we are the types of
models we build how we got here and and
paths forward the reason I put Charlie
Chaplin from modern times here is I
think it's nice to think well it's not
nice but it is an apt analogy to think
ourselves as like building things that
were kind of stuck in stuff inside of
simultaneously so whenever I see or hear
about models out there that are doing
harm I think of Charlie Chaplin being
sucked up into into the clockwork and
trying to fix it as he builds it um I
also think you know silent cinema from
early to mid 20th century there's
actually a little a lot of lessons to do
with industrialization of society that
are applicable now Charlie Chaplin
Buster Keaton and and Jacques Tati a
three really good examples maybe Howard
Lloyd as well but I'm not here to talk
about the silent cinema cinema of the
early 20th century I'm here to talk
about we're where we are initially okay
so Michael Jordan was a Berkeley who
happens to be literally the Michael
Jordan of machine learning but also in a
lot of ways figuratively for me anyway
the greatest of all time
published in the inaugural have a data
science review in June this year an
article called AI the revolution hasn't
happened yet and what he tells us there
is that a lot of us essentially are
building societal scale and planetary
scale inference and decision-making
systems that impact and involve machines
humans and the environment and he makes
very clear that what we're missing is a
principled system of engineering and
design in building these systems and he
makes the point that just as humans
build buildings and bridges before civil
engineering structural engineering
existed as disciplines we're essentially
doing that with at scale planetary ins
societal scale algorithms and here we go
here he says what we're missing is an
engineering discipline with principles
of analysis and design and I think we do
have a number of things to learn from
structural and civil engineering but
before we go there I kind of want to
before I point out what we what we are
doing I want to kind of consider a bit
tongue-in-cheek and provocatively what
we do have and essentially we have what
David Donoho calls recycled intelligence
so this is one of the one of the great
classification challenges of trying to
figure out chihuahua heads versus
muffins okay there are even a few there
that are I'm not sure which you which is
which there's even one which i think is
a chihuahua dressed as a muffin but I'll
let you pick out which which one that is
but essentially to do this type of
challenge as we know you need thousands
of hand labeled examples and that's
exactly David Donoho's point which when
we're when we call it artificial
intelligence essentially a lot of the
time we're getting humans to do a task
and we're recycling that intelligence by
getting computers to mimic it usually in
a quite fragile brittle brittle way okay
I wonder what adversarial attacks on
these Chihuahuas would look like so
let's just talk a bit about how
structural failure can occur in
structural engineering in civil
engineering because there are some
analogs in productized data science
products so one way is that the
structure is not strong enough to
support the law
a second way is fatigue or corrosion a
third is manufacturing error or
defective materials and a fourth is lack
of consideration of unexpected problems
ok such as environmental factors or bad
actors which we think a lot about when
deploying algorithms at scale
what type of analogs and this isn't
intended to be exhaustive at all but
what type of analogs can we see in data
science workflows I'm actually missing
ok yep so structural failure in in data
science
the first analog we can think of is poor
design we'll see many examples where we
expect data science work to generalize
and it just doesn't ok
another aspect of poor design is not all
users are considered so if you're
building bridges you really want to
think about who's going to be walking
across those bridges and if you're
building buildings you want to be
thinking about who's going to be inside
those buildings right fatigue or
corrosion one analog is lack of
maintenance that's how fatigue and
corrosion in manifest themselves an
example here is model concept drift
david drift in in deployed algorithms
world the third is failure due to bad
parts training data bad assumptions
relying too much on one one objective
function and also thinking about failure
due to data flow between these parts as
well and the fourth environmental
factors lack of consideration of
unexpected problems one example there
bad actors such as Cambridge analytical
so I just wanted to say a bit about
building before structural engineering
existed this is the oldest known
building or the oldest surviving
building I could find on the internet
anyway which maybe we just because we
are the information civilization now
that is the oldest known building it's
called the can of Bannen a in France
which was built around 5000 BC ok now
what we see on the right here is
buckling which people knew existed but
it wasn't until 1757 that Euler was the
first person to mathematically describe
Buckley and discover
formula for his critical load which
tells us how much mass you can put on a
beam of a particular material while it
can still handles supporting supporting
that way so essentially for thousands of
years before we even knew how really how
buckling worked we were building
buildings and I argue that's where we
are essentially in the systems we're
building there may not be a precise
analog of buckling but I think it's
instructive to recognize that a lot of
these things were built beforehand it
was only maybe 50 years after he
discovered buckling or the formula for
his critical load that the institution
of civil engineers was was first founded
for which I think is also quite telling
now Michael Jordan so yeah what I'm
going to do now is go through a series
of case in cases of where where
engineering these types of inference and
decision-making systems at scale I'm
going to talk about medicine to start so
Michael Jordan tells an example in in
this article about when his wife was
pregnant around a decade and a half ago
when the ultrasound showed up white
spots around the heart the specialist
the geneticist in the room said that
these are possible markers for Down
syndrome and the risk of Down syndrome
has gone up to one in twenty Judah these
white white markers the specialist
suggested or said amniocentesis was an
option to tell more but that's fatal in
1 out of 300 cases
Michael Jordan being the Michael Jordan
of machine learning and statistics then
went and did some research into all the
work had been done that have been done
to tell that these white spots were
markers for Down syndrome and what he
found is that the paper that was being
referenced and the body of research was
done on trials that had lower resolution
the ultrasound had lower resolution and
what he discovered was that the white
spots were most likely white Noiz little
white noise and giving false false
positives due to the increased
resolution of the modern ultrasound when
he told the specialist that they said oh
that makes sense because when we got
these new machines we did see an uptick
in
in in Down syndrome markers what was
scarier was that Jordan then went into
the back of the envelope calculation to
discover that thousands of people on the
day that he went would have received
this diagnosis and a handful would have
had fetal fatalities so now let's talk
about engineering finance at a planetary
scale this is this is something that we
saw on November 7 so this is a few days
ago right where David Hanson creative
Ruby on Rails and co-founder and CTO of
Basecamp discovered that the Apple card
was offering him 20x the credit limits
and it was his wife although all there
although all their finances together and
this this kicked up quite a storm on
social media and we even saw Steve
Wozniak
come into the conversation saying that
he can borrow 10 times as much as his
wife on their Apple cards and was in the
Act states that algorithms have obvious
flaws and a huge number of people would
say we love our technology but we are no
longer in control I also include a post
by Linda lace wall superintendent here
of New York State Department of
Financial Services who's responded to
this and she's also put a call out on on
Twitter for people who encounter these
types of algorithms so it's great to see
that even in a few days we have
something opening up like like this and
then conversations start to occur around
it how else are we seeing finance being
engineered at that scale oh I'll remind
you of the mid 20th century practice of
redlining in which surveyors from the
home owned the homeowners Loan
Corporation would call a certain
neighborhoods red to deem them hazardous
for bank loans neighborhoods were red
line due to the presence of African
Americans immigrants or Jewish people
it's been illegal for 50 years now and
yet it still occurs in a variety of ways
just not as it as explicitly in the past
couple of years we've seen you know a
lot of research and
articles published about modern-day
redlining how banks block people of
color from home ownership a recent study
showed that in Baltimore race impacts
mortgage lending more than income does
and studies have found that proprietary
credit score algorithms have a
discriminatory impact on borrowers of
color as well so this is still still
happening you may also remember a huge
fee s go around predatory payday loan
ads so these words that were served to
people who made Google queries such as
we need money to pay I need money to pay
rent and and they would have I think
annual interest rates of up to 2,000
percent regularly between 300 and 900
but up to up to 2,000 percent and in
2016
Google banned all payday loan ads on
their platform and this seems like a
like a really good thing right and I
think it is in a lot of respects I do
want to ask the question do we want
these types of societal scale finance
finance engineering decisions to be made
by big tech companies such as Google so
I think that's something we need to need
to discuss I'll also mention that Saphir
Noble has discussed data redlining in in
the form of something called
technological redlining and this book in
particular it's essentially about the
power of algorithms and the way those
digital decisions reinforce oppressive
social relationships and enact new modes
of racial profiling and these are what's
a fear Noble calls technological
redlining so we can see in 20 it is 2013
what what Google autocompletes for why
are black women so as compared to wire
while white women so and I'll mention in
passing also the the bias inherent in a
lot of facial recognition one thing is
it's far worse at predicting people of
color and something I discovered
recently is that I wondered why this is
why this is the case and essentially
it's baked in
the design principles of our systems and
it's a historical and cultural artifact
that essentially and I'm going to quote
from the right-hand article here from
from lens from the times that
photography is not just a system of
calibrating light but a technology of
subjective decisions okay
so previously when you sent your film to
get developed lab technicians would use
the image of a white woman and this is
called a shirley card with brown hair as
the measuring stick our Wentz against
which they calibrated the colors so even
our original design of the data that we
use in these biased algorithms was
biased itself so all of these
essentially micro and macro decisions
that are made impact how the algorithm
then then behaves so we've talked about
finance in medicine I want to talk about
engineering society at scale in in a
number of ways I think Kathy O'Neill
does a wonderful job of not only
discussing in weapons of mass
destruction a lot of the algorithms that
that are harmful out there but
developing a language a system of
physics a way to describe what we're
encountering in terms of she's very much
interested in algorithms that are
important secretive and harmful and in
particular ones that impact fine finance
livelihood decisions around Liberty and
decisions around information three
examples are the value-added model for
teachers which is a highly sensitive
model that will output a teacher's
performance in the education system
which is used for promotion hiring and
firing decisions it's a black black box
proprietary model that the teachers have
have no insight into principals
superintendents have no insight into so
a widespread hiring model for minimum
wage positions that has in it a
personality test that essentially
performs a mental health assessment
which is illegal
and and and Kathy goes into detail in
this book with an example of a man named
Kyle beam who essentially didn't receive
I think something like six or seven
positions all of which had this mental
health assessment embedded in it and
then there's the notorious case which I
think a lot of us are aware of now of
North points compass refers recidivism
risk algorithm that's used in in parole
hearings which is biased against people
of color the other example that I want
to bring to light of Engineering Society
at scale is Virginia Eubanks book
automating inequality it's it's it's a
wonderful wonderful piece of
investigative journalism among other
things where Eubanks looks these
problems at very different scales from a
very high level how it impacts our
society at large and then goes on the
ground and speaks with particular case
workers and people who are impacted by
by these algorithms the examples are an
attempt at automating welfare
eligibility systems in Indiana then a
model that's used to determine whether
our children or at risk of abuse in in
Pennsylvania and the third one is an
algorithm used in LA to determine who's
going to get housing out of the cities
tens of thousands of homeless people and
what we see emerge in all these cases is
that those at highest risk had all types
of personal data collected with no
regard or little regard for security
privacy discussing with them they were
classified as risky investments and
problematic parents and there were also
targets of vast networks of surveillance
and one example is the child neglect
algorithm which in rolling out its
predictions it unfairly and unduly
targeted black people and one reason and
we'll see that this is a reason a lot of
the the algorithms fail and it's
referred to as a glitch a lot of the
time but it's it's really baked into it
is the use of proxies as a proxy for
maltreatment of children in this model
rather than our treatment itself the
proxy that was used was something called
re referral which includes anonymous and
mandated reports of abuse which are
reported over three times more often for
black and biracial families according to
Eubanks
on a switch gears a bit now so this is
kind this is like a smorgasbord of all
the dangers we're facing out there I'd
should have preface this by saying we're
all doing a lot of great work as well
but I'm not here to talk about that
hopefully some other people are today
if not I'll probably get the one back
downtown is how we're engineering
information at a planetary scale so I
encourage you all to follow the work of
Guillaume Chaz Lowe who was a software
engineer at YouTube and left when his
cries or plays or attempts to have a
discussion around the dangers what
YouTube is doing for our information
civilization he left them on the eve of
the u.s. presidential election in 2016
and all his jupiter notebooks are
available online to see these analysis
analyses he seeded out a significant
tenth are thousands of searches on
YouTube and found that more than 80% of
recommended videos were favorable to
Trump independent of whether the initial
query was Trump or Clinton and I to put
this in context I want you to know that
approximately 70% of views on YouTube
are generated by the recommendation
algorithm okay and at this point I think
it's changed now but at this point
YouTube was optimizing for view time and
of course due to their essential
essentially their surveillance revenues
and advertising revenues now people have
said in optimizing for view time it's
just showing people what they want to
see and that that catches me oh my god
is is that true I don't think it's true
it isn't showing people what they want
to see it's showing people what will
keep their eyes stuck to the screen for
the longest time and I think I like the
analogy as a net to effect Qi users she
said this is essentially analogous to an
automated school cafeteria loading
plates with fatty salty and sweet food
because it's figured out that's what
keeps kids there the longest okay so
we've got a lot of kind of short-term
and long-term considerations at play
here as well once again follow Chaz
Lowe's work he's got wonderful
interactive visualizations of what was
happening
at the time among other things he also
points out that at least then when you
search for is the earth flat or round
and follow recommendations five times
more than 90% of recommended videos
state that the earth is flat ok so maybe
it is the last example I want to give of
engineering information and a planetary
scale and I think of in terms and
essentially media Netflix also follow
Netflix technical blog it's amazing
their blog and stitch fix algo blogger
two of my favorites they have a
wonderful post about how they've a be
tested thumbnails right and also to put
this in context over 80% of content
watched on Netflix is discovered through
the recommendation engine as well for
that's worth so the example they give is
that let's say they think you might want
to watch oh wait I've got a point
I forgot you had one thing to remember
Hugo point at this screen so yeah if
Netflix thinks you might be interested
in watching pulp fiction and you've been
watching a bunch of uma Thurman movies
previously they'll show you a thumbnail
with uma Thurman on it if they think you
want to watch pop fiction and you've
been watching a bunch of John Travolta
movies recently and I have no idea why
you would have been doing that in all
honesty and I don't know why they have
an included face it maybe they don't
have face off but if you're watching
John Travolta movies I feel like should
watch the most underappreciated movie of
the mid-90s being face off but what then
happened is that several people
discovered several people of color
discovered that they'll be heading that
they had thumbnails targeted at them
that totally misrepresented the movie
they that was being advertised so this
example like like father these actors as
it says here heard maybe 10 minutes
cumulative screen time in the movie and
the cast as you can see down here was
Kristen Bell Kelsey Grammer and Seth
Rogan no idea why you put those three in
a movie together no idea why you okay no
I'm not gonna go on about Frasier in
but what we have here is absolutely a
misrepresentation of what what the movie
is because this has been a be tests that
are experimented enough to say that
these people of color will watch watch
this if it's shown as such Netflix said
it doesn't track users wraith race or
ethnicity of course we know there are
lots of proxies for all types of
different things that algorithms can
pick up the most famous when thinking
about race is zip code being used
instead of race but you can imagine that
viewing history can be a relatively good
proxy for race or ethnicity so
presumably that's what's happening here
but guess what we don't know right in
wrapping up where we are I wanted to
just inject a bit of positivity in terms
of talking about the virtuous cycle of
AI where in which we give data to
companies they get more data to improve
the product they get more users and then
they generate more data and improve the
product and I direct you all to Andrew
he has a wonderful a our transformation
playbook where he goes through a lot of
these these types of things so this is
all well and good but I I wouldn't be
doing my job if I didn't tell you about
the not so virtuous cycle of AI and this
is from a wonderful book by Shoshana
Zubov and I love these images as well
because it's you know very difficult
material but it's almost comic book II
which I which I really dig so down here
we see the virtuous cycle of AI but then
on top of that
all of what Zubov refers to as our
behavioral surplus is is rendered into
prediction products that are sold
essentially on behavioral futures
markets that then come back into the
business as what she refers to as
surveillance surveillance revenue and in
this sense the product isn't not
necessarily aligned with what the users
us and among many other people how what
what we want and I'll I'll quote Zubov
directly when a lot of the time we hear
if you don't pay for the product you are
the product
Zubov says forget the cliched that if
it's free you are the product you're not
the product you are the abandoned
carcass the product derives from the
surplus that is ripped from your life
okay so there you go I didn't mean to
take it that far but Zubov definitely
meant to take it that far and I'll speak
a bit more more about this
Zubov wonderfully she develops really a
kind of a wonderful system of
classification and laws of physics are
around this in terms of talking about
the different economies that are at work
here I'll speak a bit about the
economies of scale where you want to get
as many clicks and user data as possible
so click streamed clicks click scream I
like the idea of clickstream data that's
what we should all be doing in protests
clickstream data is involved in these
economies of scale economies of scope
involve enlarging the type of data
collected in two manners first by
extension into the real world via IOT
and wearables may have noticed that
Google is acquiring Fitbit for 2.1
billion dollars which involves them
acquiring 12 years of user data so
that's increasing extension into the
real world the second is by increasing
its debt to render what's referred to as
intimate patterns of the self such as
psychology emotion and mood such data
can be retrieved from digital assistants
including voice assistants and social
media platforms such as Facebook the
third way that these systems will get
into our world is economies of behavior
and that essentially sees surveillance
capitalists in Zubov framing modify user
behavior why would companies want to
modify our behavior well their
surveillance revenue is based on the
accuracy of their prediction products so
why why predict with error bars when you
can define the outcome right seems seem
smart to me
examples of changing user behavior or
Facebook getting people to vote by
showing users that their friends have
voted which may be a good thing but
let's talk about it
insurers and employers incentivizing
exercise using fitness trackers by
lowering print insurance premiums car
insurers incentive izing safe
safer driving doing the same and my
favorite example is Pokemon go in in in
which cafes bars and restaurants were
able to get more traffic into their
places of business by paying Pokemon go
to put Pokemon in the place places of
business
little-known fact perhaps you all some
of you knew this Niantic the software
development company that built Pokemon
go was formed as an internal startup
within Google and they experimented with
Pokemon go with a paper visit model
which is analogous of course to the
revolutionary pay-per-click model which
would Google brought in in the early
early noughties with all that having
been said that's kind of the state in a
lot of ways of where we are and across
different parts of parts of the world I
want to talk about how we how we got
here ok one of the ways we got here is
that builders people building these
systems just haven't represented users
there's been a serious lack of empathy
with respect to who's impacted by these
algorithms when they're deployed at
scale across society I can speak to a
lot of what's happened in in in tech I
think and people such as fear Noble and
Rachel Thomas and AI now as well I'm
have a lot to say about how it isn't
actually a pipeline pipeline problem
that you know there are you know
exclusionary cultures and in the
workplace and that Silicon Valley is a
very good example of this and I think
thinking about this at scale and at
large even in terms of the automated
decision systems used in society such as
the recidivism risk model what Kathy
O'Neil talks about in weapons of mass
destruction and all the examples
Virginia Eubanks describes the people
building these models aren't on the
ground with users and they don't
represent users so this is something
that definitively will need to change
and we'll get get to that so this is
kind of once again a smorgasbord of
examples of how how we got where we are
that's something cultural there are
technical reasons there are historical
reasons and I'll take us for through a
few of the
another is a paradigm shift from
traditional software to software 2.0 as
popularized by Andrey Carpathia his blog
post his medium post is fantastic and I
recommended he formalizes it essentially
as software in the software 2.0 world
software will be written in the weights
of neural networks I think about it
slightly differently that in the
software 2.0 world it will be defined
reinforcement learning aside it will be
defined by training data and objective
functions loss functions okay
so we're no longer you know writing out
although all the for loops and although
all the if statements of what happens
but we're entering a world where which
essentially we're building an
infrastructure that assumes and then
opera operationalizes the data and the
loss function as an infallible and
objective foundation for decision making
okay Cassie called Cassie kozakov chief
decision scientist at Google cloud but
this really well follow her as well
she's got wonderful posts that she
writes explicitly as the tools get
better and better you'll eventually see
that there are only two real
instructions in ml and AI optimized this
goal on this data set okay and one
example of this happening very recently
was Amazon scrapping their recruiting
tool that showed bias against women and
it was the training data in particular
which was biased there I'll encourage
you to play this game which I I think
it's out of Mozilla labs or it's
definitely affiliated with Mozilla
called survival of the best-fit where
you play an executive who's received
some venture capital hiring and and then
you need to automate the process for
reasons of efficiency and and and you
see what happens there in a number of
use use cases it's a 10-minute game
survival that's a great name as well
survival of the best fit so I'll
encourage you to check that out now now
another reason we got where we are
essentially has to do with objective
functions and and proxies so you may
know good hearts law which states that
when a measure becomes a target that
ceases to be a good measure now I don't
know whether this story is apocryphal or
a lot of
seem to think it's true so I'll state it
as let's say apocryphal truth but this
is a case in which Soviet factories were
given targets based on the number of
nails they produced so they built
thousands of tiny nails which weren't
useful and then they were asked but
optimized for the weight of the nails
made so that they then built a few giant
heavy nails so the what's really
happening there is that proxies are
being used to replace goals and nobody's
getting what what they want and we saw
this be really impactful even I mean a
few weeks ago with a national health
care algorithm that affects millions of
people in which and once again it's
biased against people of color because
it focused on costs for health care as
opposed to actual health of patients and
citizens as Rachel Thomas has said and
once again I encourage you to follow all
of all of her work the problem with
metrics is a big problem for AI because
most AI approaches optimize metrics any
metric is just a proxy they can and will
be gained and they overemphasize
short-term concerns and that's something
that we saw in in the case of the
YouTube recommendation algorithm another
historical fact um and model I think
that has led to where we are now is the
just a VC back growth model and when I
think about this I'd point you to Brin
and pages I also found out recently that
the PageRank algorithm isn't called the
PageRank algorithm because it ranks
pages it's actually named after Larry
Page so I don't know if that naivety
what your hand if you knew that okay I'm
only slightly embarrassed so in their
paper the anatomy of a large scale
hypertextual web search engine that's
the quickest I've ever said that in
their appendix they have an appendix
called advertising and mixed motives in
which they state the predominant
business model for commercial search
engines is advertising the goals of the
advertising business model do not always
correspond to providing quality search
to users they then go on to say we
believe the issue of advertising causes
enough
incentives that is crucial to have a
competitive search engine that is
transparent and in the academic realm
you couldn't you couldn't make this up
okay so why then did they adopt an
advertising business model when 2000 the
dot-com the dot-com bubble burst right
and VCS were freaking out Steven Levy in
his book about Google wrote and I quote
verbatim the VCS were screaming bloody
murder Tex salad days were over and it
wasn't certain that Google would avoid
becoming another crushed radish I've
never heard that term before but I
definitely liked it AdWords had just
been launched to some success so Google
went full throttle on the advertising
model to not become another crush radish
another question is why did the US
government allow this type of
surveillance to continue particularly
when the FTC had issued a report in 2000
recommending allege legislation to
regulate online privacy one of the
reasons was September 11 and a national
security
so after 9/11 the objective became
security over privacy and the data that
Google was able to collect along with
the Patriot Act made it easier for the
government to spy on or ordinary
Americans one other historical fact well
it's very current as well but I want to
alert everyone's attention to is the
existence from 1996 of section 230 of
the Communications Decency Act which
essentially was developed to my
understanding to protect ISPs from being
responsible for stuff posted on their on
their platforms so I bitten through
there through the networks but is the
main section that's used by tech
companies and social media platforms to
not be responsible for what people are
posting and now in Congress both parties
have singled out section 234 attack from
opposite sides though in particular
after h n once again hosted a
hate-filled manifesto that was connected
to a mass shooting so i've got five
minutes left so I'm actually going to
all these slides are available I'm going
to skip through a bit to talk about
paths for
and the first thing I want to mention I
like cold polanyi's model for thinking
about the relationship of humanity to
technology and market forces he thought
of something called will conceptualized
a double movement called the double
movement which the first movement was
the push for post-industrial revel
industrial revolution marketization of
society and the second movement against
it were the social movements that push
back and reasserted humanity and society
through for example labor laws and and
tariffs and I want to think about the
types of places these can come from
today in the pushback against all these
data revolutions and AI revolutions
we're seeing everywhere I'm a big fan of
the way Matt Jones and Chris Wiggins
formalize this in their course here data
past present and future and they have an
idea that you know the story of data is
really a story of truth and power and
essentially how truth and powers are
contested there's a YouTube video of
Chris discussing this course at
Princeton which I direct you to chris
states explicitly that usually when
people develop new powers they're using
it to defend their own power rather to
empower the defenseless and I think
that's what we've seen a lot of in all
of these examples and and chris
encourages us all to look at the present
contests among the powers such as the
contest around section 230 in order to
understand the future and formalizes
these contests and and powers as an
unstable three player game between we
see let's get this right and this is of
course one of Chris's slides between
industry yet private companies
government and then the private market
and I'd like to think of this as a
framework for thinking about how the
second part of this double movement in
this data and algorithm revolution can
occur so what are paths forward I really
recommend you check out the AI now
report from from 2018 they've got a lot
of different recommendations one in
terms of how these powers are contested
is to think about beyond the pipeline
model that tech companies just have to
go beyond the pipeline model and commit
to
dressing the practices of exclusion and
discrimination in their workplaces labor
labor movements an employee walkout so
happening more and more we've seen
Amazon workers Google workers stop
Google participating in in in project
maven Microsoft employees protests the
work with ice and I quote Microsoft
employees verbatim they said as the
people who build the technologies that
Microsoft profits from we refuse to be
complicit we are part of a growing
movement comprised of many across the
industry who recognized the grave
responsibility that those creating
powerful technology have to ensure what
they build is used for good and not for
harm we recently saw tableau workers
walked off after and tableau was sold to
ice see down here maybe it's fine
because having ice use tableau will stop
them from scaling now this is all well
and good employee walkouts
but as ruh-huh Benjamin riots and this
is literally me just taking a photo of a
book as well I think the future of
slides is just photos of books but um
so what ruja wrote is that this kind of
informed refusal by workers expressed by
Google Microsoft employees is certainly
necessary as we build a movement to
counter what she refers to as a new gym
code but we cannot wait for worker
sympathies to sway the industry she
gives a number of examples of
community-based activism that I would
encourage you all to look into and and
work with a lot of your skills would be
applicable to these these types of
projects the digital defense playbook
intended to give marginalized
communities a set of tools to reclaim
agency and self-determination over their
data and how it's used the cop
accountability project here empowers
organizations and communities across New
York City to hold police officers
accountable for human rights violations
they run a database that tracks police
misconduct in in the city and it's used
by public defense civil rights and human
rights organizations other organizations
such as data for black lives and the
Detroit Community Technology Project are
doing a lot of great work here I'm going
to need to wrap up in a couple of
minutes but I look forward to discussing
this a lot more with
in office hours which I'm really excited
about I wanted to say a bit about
legislative change we're seeing a lot of
pushback against facial recognition
technology data data ownership right to
data deletion right to be forgotten
these types of things in GDP are
Democrats in California proposing a bill
that would create a set of user data
rights similar to Europe's GDP are with
the facial-recognition stuff we may not
even need legislation if we all become
fans of the Insane Clown Posse because
it turns out that Juggalo makeup blocks
facial recognition technology that's
that's clearly a joke other things to
think about as future music but work
that's currently happening the future of
algorithmic audits thinking about our
FDA for an FDA for algorithms and in
fact I found out yesterday that I think
there have been fifteen to twenty five
algorithms in the health space that have
actually been FDA approved
I'll also signal a bunch of other
organizations for you to watch out for
and to work with such as AI now data
kind data and society all of those are
in the city fat ml also along with black
in AI women and machine learning queer
in AI and Lennox in AI all that having
been said just want to give you a few
takeaways what you can do today besides
go to the rest of talks and speak with
all the speakers contribute to any of
these projects I would encourage you to
read and talk and educate widely we're
in positions are privileged here
pressure your employer's to consider the
impact of your work on all stakeholders
and do the same to yourself pressure to
move past the pipeline model I'd
encourage you to define principles in an
ethical manner and design for them in a
principled and robust manner in your
work and continually ask Who am i
building these bridges for and and who's
walking across them and with that I'll
wrap up thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]